if everyone's just going to go to their
own little corners and we're all going
to live in our own little pods and our
sort of semi-virtual realities with very
little in common then you don't have
much of a country
we need to get together again not just
by moving
moving out into more spacious
territories but also by meeting up
getting together having thanksgiving
having christmas celebrating birthdays
we haven't been allowed to do that by
the psychos in the cdc
and the public health experts and the
politicians for a year now though good
news from the cdc
a year into two weeks to slow the spread
they're going to let us see one another
again in very limited circumstances
cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people can visit with other
fully vaccinated people in small
gatherings indoors
without wearing masks or physical
distancing so what does this mean
if you and a friend or you and a family
member are both vaccinated
you can have dinner together wearing
masks without distancing
you can visit your grandparents if you
have been vaccinated
and they have been too i know that i can
see my friends
i know that i can go meet up with people
at their houses or
in public i know that i can see my
relatives
because i've been doing that for a year
because i've been ignoring all of you
awful tyrants all of you awful lab coat
dictators
who have been changing your guidance day
by day changing your reasoning day by
day but somehow the
the rules always seem to stay the same
or get worse
i know i can do all that i'm pleased
that you the rest of the people who have
been following you
very foolishly will now be told that but
we've known this for a very long time
i uh strongly recommend that you
take advantage of this opportunity if
you have not gone and seen your friends
and relatives
you absolutely should go do it but the
cdc is not going to let go of all the
power yet it's either saying well if
it's a
if it's a vaccinated person seeing
someone who is unvaccinated who knows
someone who's this then you can't you've
got to
forget about it forget about it i think
they know that they're losing power
and i think they know that people you
just look around you can see people are
just violating it they've had enough of
this stuff
and so they're going to start to let up
on it just ignore these people
there is no re they have just been wrong
and wrong and wrong again
they have the public health expert
apparatus
has in some cases been outright
dishonest and
i just don't see any reason to to pay
any attention to them
whatsoever you've got to get back
together it is disordered
to muzzle yourself in public to not be
able to see your fellow citizens
smiling faces it is disordered
not to go see your friends and relatives
not to gather together man is a social
animal
and there are there are more important
things in life
than uh a a cough if you're
in an extraordinary extraordinarily
at-risk
group you know be prudent prudence is a
virtue
but that's not really what i notice most
people i know who are sort of up there
in age
they're the least likely people to wear
their masks because they know better
they're the least likely people to
refuse to see anybody
the people i notice doing this are all
these perfectly healthy millennials
who have a totally warped sense
of themselves in the world it's the sort
of meghan markle generation
they don't they've just totally
gone gone upside down come together
everybody i beg you if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you